[Music]
Hausa gone Rose my name is Pierre
welcome back to no stepha
no spell I can never say it right
it means vampire in Russian I have no
Transylvanian that's not language all
right I got a few motive actually so I
think I'm gonna do pretty door just
totally closed by itself I don't like
that all right should we go in here
oh yeah and if we go here these [ __ ]
up here I have we kill them bowels
battle separate oh I found a small
halfback ye well and needed help I all
right
the thing is when I go up here they are
gonna [ __ ] come at me alright
crucifix [ __ ] or or I have one
bullet I have one more layer what the
[ __ ] Oh close me all right scare me
alright school
cycle this cycle its cycle we got a
problem I got a problem
I don't know what I did not go as
planned I know I say BAM and I sent me a
[ __ ] score oh my god
all right I've been told I'm supposed to
punish it oh oh I know you used to
crucifix and then you punch him in the
face I got I got this
no problemo señoras plus now I don't
have any anymore have that makes sense
let's just go here take the help bag say
how do him sup Brown go back oh it's
needing perfect now awesome save just
cuz that I didn't know it was random
alright let's use our tactic
we got this get this I have a crucifix
wait where's the knuckles
I think this victim two nine eight know
in seven right good the big by the
pallet how it's helped in my face
damn it I'm glad we saved at least where
do we say that here and we're back with
afraid of monsters dying a million times
god damn it God that it's a cool it's
cool
we're just getting Charlotte bro don't
worry I got this I am an expert
god damn I just wasted all right all
right just focus focus by the power of
Grayskull
back up yes and now we got a bunch y'all
slapping face it Oh there too by the
power of Jesus power up job now it
doesn't work I'm outta here
Oh what the [ __ ] ever is floor that's I
cool oh I can't do this it's too much it
doesn't give you a break you round then
something comes out of the floor
I don't appreciate it not one bit
I don't like it I just like put my pride
all right now I don't have any ammo I
don't really understand what's going on
but him power of Jesus cries well save
me where where are those little [ __ ]
by the powers of fact all right
Japanese for the night they do a lot of
damage they do a lot of damage seriously
Oh busy you should use the crucifix and
then punch it doesn't work it was bad
[ __ ] come on
I just got oh oh I know I know we can
use these let's use these all right I
got this it's not problem oh no oh wait
I saw that I had to pull it all right
let's go here it's scared so much
all right we got some light that's not
happening
how long was chair all right let's see
here I don't press this floor nothing on
bit all right a lot of health actually
absolutely nothing else come on back up
chop nice mother [ __ ] ah that's how
three just got to be kidding me
how the hell am i ah ah ah for I mean if
I had the gun I could at least shoot
that one what the fine I'm just gonna
take what the frick beef racket of true
yes I did say that I don't know why the
loading screen is so slow I mean it's no
[ __ ] game but it's beyond me and
attacked across
I was told right let's ready to generate
my stamina let's try luring them out one
by one
Wow Webre talk about me stop knees back
up chop knees up back up back up back up
dig Wow Wow what else I'm out of here
I'm out of here I'm out of here I'm out
of here
of here I'm out of here I'm outta here
I'm outta here I'm outta here I'm out of
here I'm out of here
I have one house I have one [ __ ]
house
[Music]
back off Japanese [ __ ]
how does he hit me if I hit that I don't
understand this game I'm sweating this
game but I don't know why my freakin
sound is just like the most horrifying
stress me a lot
I will have my period soon if this what
okay I know I know this is wrong it's
fear Tyco oh how I switch it too easy I
guess
no that I start a new game now I didn't
really look what I clicked for I mean
easy it would probably be better for me
cuz I'm not very good at this game but I
think it started a new game let's see I
[Music]
would where are we yeah it started in
your game
[ __ ] it through and that leaves that
alright
what okay let's use the [ __ ] everything
in wrong tactic just just [ __ ] the
[ __ ] alright my stamina you can't
probably see it because the resolution
is wrong but I'm waiting afraid to
regenerate I'm gonna run like a
[ __ ]
back off please thank you feedback
coming through back home with room all
right back up please
all right yeah odd to even out out back
up your dogs all right let's go let's go
let's go let's go
I had worse days in my life where you
know Diamond Dogs
I hate all Namath baggage here must die
I hate all of ya team up on me oh that
didn't work very well
one more try
is it hot in here or is it just me one
more time I have a crucifix that is
something in this mess is wait for the
run left yeah
hey bruh heightened powers Jesus power
Jesus if I were Jesus power demonize
ESCO ESCO that's cool that's cool demon
august I get it I get it I get it I get
it I get it you're upset you hug me but
I'm not your dinner I'm not your dad I
told ya why don't you hide in here in
here it's cold it's all right down in
here
yes boss yes Oh what do you want
back off [ __ ] all right they're after
me they're after me they're after me
back up back up power of Jesus
by God
[Music]
[ __ ] lock doors everywhere am i
walking these circles I'm alive it's
America thank Satan back up [ __ ] Hey
thank god you're here oh thank god
you're here dr. Hammond she a little
terrible like demons everywhere
have you found out Emily on Sophia no I
haven't found anyone you must succeed or
you'll be I am pretty [ __ ] anyway I
got my medical equipment in my trunk and
the mainlanders take it then a little
bit of a hurry
god damn it I am so what
back up don't do that Dennis sir
something please hey Phil something it's
gonna kill me I don't wanna die now I'm
too young and handsome ah take am that I
have a medical ID give me this
Oh have it all right all right give me
that keep up freeloaders I'm flying shut
up okay power sink all right [ __ ] you he
couldn't do us stop okay okay
defend us you shut up Jesus Christ Jesus
penis everywhere I come on Easter blanks
5l I am so screwed I'm so scared
[Music]
wait yes yes enough by the power of save
them I fell now I think I need a new
tactic or something holy [ __ ]
polishes it's a freaking like I don't
know it's like grounding I [ __ ]
marathon playing this game I gotta add
vetere Broyles I'm sorry I don't even
know anymore
like a new fave you enjoyed it
[Music]
you